let's get right to CBS News chief
medical correspondent dr. Jon LaPook is
here to help us understand this
investigation I think people should know
that there are literally hundreds of
different manufacturers making devices
and the juice it must be very difficult
to sort it all out how our investigators
going about it well they're trying to
find the culprit or culprits but it's
tough unlike an e coli or salmonella
outbreak they're not quite sure what
they're looking for when you think about
it these devices are like miniature
chemistry sets you know you have all
this this liquid you're heating it up
you have all these chemicals that are
created what do you look one what's the
culprit it's like looking for a needle
in a haystack
you don't know what the needle it looks
like the tobacco analysts at Wells Fargo
say 22 million American adults they it's
been around for about 10 years why are
we just hearing about all these health
problems now yeah the question is is has
something been added to this whether
it's examining or something going on
that that's now and it wasn't there
before
and the clue to that is that the cases
in Illinois doubled this summer compared
to the same period last year so it's not
it doesn't look like it's something
that's been going on for a long time
that we just went that's a 50 it's
actually new that doesn't tell you that
regular vaping is safe I mean it hasn't
been around long enough for us to know
and they've been concerns for years that
we're we're addicting an entire
generation of young people who weren't
smoking to start off with and that who
knows where the long-term consequences
are and again the experts say do not use
e-cigarettes let's pay attention to that
yeah the CDC I wanted to say CDC says
that you should consider not using and
other organizations are saying don't use
there is a little controversy about that
all right thank you dr. Foote